bonjour le sujet d'aujourd'hui peut vous
paraître un peu facile
oh là là elle parle de maladie en pleine
pandémie mais ça faisait un moment que
j'avais envie de m'y attaquer alors
pourquoi pas et puis pour une fois qu'on
a un sujet que lucrecia et moi avons
connu ça se fait ça va être l'occasion
de se rapprocher de renforcer nos liens
de jouer à la lettre comment ça reste
loin de moi
[Musique]
avant de commencer je tiens à signaler
que préparer cette vidéo n'a pas été des
plus simples entre les historiens qui
pensent que la lèpre n'apparaît qu'au
11e siècle ceux qui disent qu'elle est
là depuis l'antiquité
le camp qui dit que la majorité des
européens en étaient atteints et ceux
qui pensent qu'ils étaient très
minoritaires
la discussion sur le nombre de
léproserie sur l'exclusion ou non des
lépreux bref la lèpre est un sujet
historique qui a subi beaucoup de débats
et un gros renouvellement
historiographique ces dernières
décennies et c'est donc aux travaux les
plus récents que j'ai décidé de me fier
le plus la lèpre est connu depuis fort
longtemps puisqu'elle est cité dans la
bible on en trouve aussi une description
dans un papyrus vieux de trois mille
cinq cents ans on sait maintenant
qu'elle a une souche unique apparues au
soudan il est environ cent mille ans et
diffusée vers le golfe persique et
larmes les historiens on n'entend plus
qu'elle apparaissait en europe qu'au bas
moyen-âge et que jusque-là l'invention
de l'est pour faisait référence à tout
un tas de maladies
il est vrai que durant toute l'antiquité
et le moyen âge on a tendance à appeler
lèpre les eczéma psoriasis vitiligo
dans cette idée la maladie aurait été
rappelé lors des premières croisades au
xième siècle on y croisait vraiment
n'importe qui cette idée est par exemple
véhiculée par voltaire qui écrit dans
son dictionnaire philosophique tout ce
que nous gagne à la fin de nos croisade
ce fut cette galles et de tout ce que
nous avions pris elle fut la seule chose
qui nous reste à michelet de son côté
parle de salles résidus des croisades
c'est absurde nous connaissions la lèpre
bien avant qu'elles ne vous coule
effectivement la lèpre apparaît en grèce
au ivème siècle avant jésus-christ il
semble qu'elles étaient rapportés
d'orient par les armes et d'alexandre le
grand
au moins les cratères amène des trucs un
peu plus utiles les hôpitaux par exemple
de l'egypte et de la grèce elle passe
alors à rome vers le premier siècle
avant jésus-christ via les armées de
pompey elle serait pas ensuite dans
toute l'europe via les conquêtes
romaines et durant l'antiquité tardive
ou au moyen-âge les contacts de plus en
plus fréquents avec les populations de
l'est de la méditerranée amplifie ce
phénomène
on retrouve la lèpre au nord de
l'angleterre au 4e siècle puis elle
gagne la scandinavie et l'islande via
les reds vikings et de la part vers les
pays bas tu es la russie en méditerranée
elle se répand aussi au maghreb en
afrique de l'ouest et en espagne via les
conquêtes musulmanes
et puis viennent les croisades et les
pèlerinages en terre sainte qui il est
vrai renforce l'incidence de la lettre
même si elle était déjà présente en
europe on estime qu'au 11e siècle
elles touchent entre 0,2 et 0,8 pour
cent de la population selon les
historiens
on peut donc pas vraiment parler
d'épidémie le mot lèpre vient du latin
les pistes qui signifie écailles en
référence à la peau des lépreux sa
bactérie est identifiée en 1873 par le
médecin norvégien en scène on l'appelle
donc aussi maladie de hansen
à mon époque on parle aussi de lèpre de
l'est prosit et ou deux mais elle rit le
mycobacterium leprae et entraîne de
forme de lettres possible
la lèpre tuberculose et non contagieuse
qui se traduit par une dépigmentation de
la peau une insensibilité et des
troubles nerveux
la lèpre plus prometteuses de son côté
est contagieuse par gouttelettes et
entraîne une plus forte atteintes
cutanées et des lésions et des nodules
ce sont les laits promat eux qui
transmettent la maladie et qui en
meurent le plus heureusement la lèpre
est assez peu contagieuse seuls 5% des
cas contactez la développe elle est
aussi nommé ready terre à mon époque on
connaissait déjà l'idée de contagion
mais on élargissait un peu elle
comprenait le contact avec un malade
le fait de respirer le même air que lui
de porter ces vêtements ou de croiser
son regard médusé
toutefois cette maladie se développe
lentement la bactérie peut incubés
pendant cinq ans les symptômes
apparaître au bout de 25 à 30 ans ainsi
beaucoup de personnes peuvent être
porteuses sans savoir dans certains
cimetières anglais des fouilles montrent
qu'au moins 19% des squelettes porte les
marques de la lettre sans que ces
personnes on est forcément été affectés
de leur vivant le discours médical sur
la lèpre se met en place au 11e siècle
les signes principaux retenus sont la
difformité du visage le dessèchement de
la peau les pustules nodules sur le
corps l'insensibilité nerveuse
l'odeur les ulcères les mutilations la
voix rauque le néré
rapt et un stade avancé le malade peut
perdre ses doigts et ses orteils sont
nés ou devenir aveugle les médecins
comprennent que la lèpre n'est pas
qu'une maladie cutanée qu'elle affecte
aussi le système nerveux au point de
paralyser le patient pour les cas les
plus atteints la sous-alimentation le
manque d'hygiène dans les villes
les mauvaises conditions météorologiques
sont les principaux critères qui
fragilise le métabolisme des hommes au
moyen-âge et permettent la contagion la
lèpre affecte particulièrement les pays
les plus froids c'est à dire la grande
bretagne et la scandinavie des
traitements proposés visent surtout à
soulager mais donne à guérir on nettoie
les peler on utilise des purgative des
onguents des huiles tout en gardant à
l'esprit que cela ne soignera pas le
patient dans des cimetières de l'épreuve
fouillé au danemark et en allemagne 80 %
des squelettes correspondent aux
critères de la lettre ce qui montre
l'efficacité des diagnostics de l'époque
comme toutes les maladies ou événements
un peu hors du commun
la lèpre suscitant tas de croyance parmi
la population
elle fut créée par le gouvernement est
véhiculée par la 5g
non on pense que la lèpre est une
punition divine individuelles qui cible
les menteurs les hérétiques
certains avancent même que la lettre se
transmet lors de rapports n'ont permis
adultérin pendant les règles ou avec des
porcs de manière générale les lépreux
sont vus comme des pêcheurs des mauvais
chrétien et on leur attribue donc
rapidement divers crimes et délits il
empoisonne raid et puis les fontaines
jetteraient des sorts à cause de cela
ils sont de plus en plus réprimé à la
fin du moyen-âge au 12e siècle certaines
oeuvres littéraires imagine qu'on peut
guérir la lettre par un bain de sang
humain
sûrement pour son apport en fer ce qui
suffit à faire accuser les la dhr
d'enlèvement d'enfants de sorcellerie et
de commerce avec le diable en 1321 dans
le sud de la france une vague de
persécutions se forment à leur rencontre
à cause d'une croyance en un complot
l'épreuve on les accuse aussi tout comme
les juifs lors des grandes épidémies de
peste au début du 16e siècle
ambroise paré écrit tous les lads
redeviennent trompeur furieux lubrique
ses idées reçues sur les l'épreuve en
plus de leurs contagion explique la
volonté de plus en plus présent de les
isoler de les exclure du monde
ils ne doivent soulever des bons
chrétiens avni par leur maladie n'est
par leur vice men sana in corpore sano
pourtant la vision de la lèpre est
ambivalente des lépreux sont aussi vues
comme touché par la justice divine et
donc choisi par dieu pour diffuser un
message le l'épreuve est celui que le
seigneur a voulu visiter plus intimement
que les autres ces salles on considère
que les lépreux seront récompensés après
leur mort beaucoup de récits de miracle
met en scène dessins portant secours à
des lépreux et jésus lui-même en guérit
les malades se livre donc à des prières
confession pénitence et pèlerinage
surtout sur les tombeaux de saints qui
ont eux-mêmes soigner leurs semblables
dès le 6e siècle les tombeaux de saint
martin de tours de saint maixent de
saint-hilaire de poitiers sont très
visités d'autres la dhr se rendre
carrément à saint jacques de compostelle
ou en terre sainte à partir du 12ème
siècle
et tant pis s'il diffuse un peu leur
maladie au passage ces deux conceptions
du lèpre pêcheurs et du lépreux élus
vont de pair et ainsi que les personnes
saines à faire preuve de charité et
d'amour envers leur prochain malades
le sort de l'épreuve dans l'ancien
testament tente déjà vers une exclusion
de la communauté le lépreux afin de
l'appeler portera ses vêtements déchirés
et aura la tête nue il se couvrir à la
barbe écrira un pur un pur aussi
longtemps qu'il aura la plaie il sera un
pur il est un pur il habitera seule sa
demeure sera hors du camp on constate
pourtant que jusqu'au xiiie siècle la
lèpre n'entraîne pas forcément une
exclusion du monde des vivants
quelques aidiez capitulaire du haut
moyen-âge tente de les isoler ailleurs
on retrouve des confiscations de biens
ou des interdictions de voyager la loi
lombarde de retard hic au septième
siècle prévoit que les lépreux doivent
être expulsés de leur ville et vivre
dans la solitude
outre ces exemples les l'épreuve peuvent
continuer de se marier d'éviter
d'acheter et d'exercer un métier
certains occupent même des fonctions de
pouvoir comme le contrat ou de
vermandois ou 2ème siècle robert bruce
en écosse où le roi baudouin iv de
jérusalem qui meurent des conséquences
de sa main
10 à 24 ans en 757 le pape etienne 2
autorise la dissolution du mariage au
cas où l'un des deux époux contracté la
lèpre pour que l'autre puisse se
remarier dans certains cas cependant les
époux restent fidèles l'un à l'autre ou
bien la personne saine accompagne son sa
conjointe s'il doit entrer en léproserie
cette autorisation est brièvement levé
au 12e siècle où l'église est un peu
réticente à casser dame ses sacrements
mais les annulations de mariage sont ré
autorisé au xiiie siècle elles ne sont
jamais automatique
le conjoint peut l'art et la veille
s'ils le souhaitent la situation évolue
donc au xiiie siècle en 1579 le concile
de latran 3 et non ce que tous les
lépreux perdent d'un statut juridique et
doivent se séparer de leur communauté
d'origine pour rejoindre les
déposeraient que nous aborderons bientôt
pour cela il fallait d'abord s'assurer
que le malade l'était bien pour éviter
aussi bien les avoirs médical que les
dépenses inutiles s'il était placé à
tort en léproserie l'église encourage
les dénonciations à partir du 13ème
siècle tout en punissant les abus
envoyez un voisin pour un proche à la
léproserie peut être un bon moyen de
s'approprier ces biens
aliénor le malade présumé est examinée
par un médecin qui cherchent les signes
de la lettre selon les régions il teste
son sens examine la couleur de son
visage la qualité de ses poils et
cheveux ses narines ça bouge son haleine
teste sa sensibilité nerveuse dans
certaines villes comme à reims ce sont
des lépreux qui examine les malades
présumés car ils sont jugés plus à même
de connaître les signes de la maladie
qui tue vitois tuiles toi tu crées par
contre il avait aussi souvent tendance à
reconnaître scène des personnes malades
pour éviter d'avoir une bouches de plus
à nourrir dans la baie creusot un jury
médicales rend ensuite son verdict
quel que soit le résultat de l'examen
c'est au patient de payer les frais de
la procédure judiciaire
dans certains cas il est déclaré pouvant
devenir la dhr il est donc maintenu dans
sa communauté d'origine mais sous
surveillance dans le cas où la lèpre est
avérée
il est envoyé en les causes de cette
séparation ne va pas sans une cérémonie
religieuse plus ou moins présente et
codifié selon la région elle est prétend
toujours vu comme une punition divine
le malade est conduit de sa maison à
l'église sur un brancard recouvert d'un
drap mortuaire une mais ces données ont
pris beaucoup et dans certains cas le
prêtre jette quelques pelletées de terre
sur le malade en disant tu es beau monde
dans d'autres endroits le malade était
carrément descendu dans une fois ce
sympathique le l'épreuve reçoit ensuite
son nouvel habit une tunique avec un
morceau des tofs souvent rouge sur la
poitrine des gants une mutuelle pour le
moan et déclic est c'est bien d'avançon
soient brûlées soit offert à la
léproserie qui l'accueille et vers
laquelle il est ensuite conduit en
procession depuis le 6e siècle on
considère que c'est à l'église de porter
assistance aux lépreux en ville c'est
l'évêque qui s'en charge dans les
campagnes c'est plutôt le rôle des
prêtres et des habitants les la dhr ne
sont pas encore isolées en groupe et
peuvent vivre dans des petites cabanes
loin des autres cette prise en charge
par l'église pose problème car toutes
les communautés n'ont pas les mêmes
moyens
certaines acceptent donc de s'occuper
des les pros de leur secteur mais
chastes ou ceux qui ne sont pas du coin
c'est l'hôpital qui se fout de la
charité
à l'époque des croisades les choses
évoluent des léproseries sont créés à
jérusalem et en 1120 et fondé l'ordre de
saint lazare le saint protecteur des
l'épreuve il s'agit d'un ordre
hospitalier et militaires dont les
membres sont tous les preuves du moins
au début et se consacre aux soins de
leurs semblables
il arrive en europe à partir de 1154 et
donne le terme de lazard est un lieu de
quarantaine pour la dhr comme la lèpre
fait un bond en avant au 12e siècle les
eaux demandés malade devient de plus en
plus nécessaire les plus riches par
charité font donc créé des léproseries
un peu partout en europe le nombre de
léproserie est sujet à débat
les premiers chiffres parlent de 20000
en europe dont 2000 en france voire 4000
selon d'autres historiens
le problème est qu'on manque de sources
pour les compter la principale est le
testament de louis 800 1226 où il
déclare légué sang soo
des projets du royaume le truc c'est que
la taille des léproseries est très
variable de la simple lutte à une et
produits pouvant accueillir jusqu'à 200
personnes comme à chartres et même là on
a fait rarement plus d'une trentaine de
malades en même temps de plus le fait
que le roi parle de 2000 léproserie un
chiffre rond tend à montrer qu aucun
inventaire précis n'existait pour ce qui
est des 20000 les produits en europe il
s'agit d'un chiffre mal interprété et
donné par mathieu par rina moines
bénédictins du xiiie siècle
il parlait en fait de 19 mille maisons
de l'ordre des hospitaliers et non de
19000 léproserie l'erreur est expliqué
dès 1891 mais continue d'être véhiculé
des enquêtes plus locale parle de 100
léproserie dans l'aisne 170 dans le
sud-ouest mais sans qu'il soit toujours
possible de trouver leurs dates de début
et de fin
la plupart des léproseries sont créés
entre mille cent cinquante mille deux
cent soixante dix et il est probable
qu'il ya eu un peu trop de léproserie
par rapport au nombre de malades
énormément de léproserie sont créés et
entretenus par donation parce que ça
fait bien pour les seniors c'est une
sorte d'investissement pour l'au delà
robert d'arbrissel le fondateur de
l'abbaye de fontevraud demande à être
enterrée dans le bâtiment des lépreux en
compagnie de ses enfants chéris les
léproseries sont aussi souvent signés
dans les testaments comment fonctionne
donc c'est léproserie les plus rurales
sont implantés à l'écart des
agglomérations et se compose de
plusieurs maisons du capam individuel
regroupés autour d'une chapelle les
lépreux il y avait un mobilier et un
secours très réduit pour créer une est
proscrit on faisait attention à
l'exposition au vent elles sont donc
souvent en sud-est des villages proches
d'une rivière ou d'une fontaine et près
d'une voie de circulation pour que les
malades puissent faire l'aumône elles ne
doivent pas non plus être trop éloigné
de la ville pour les mêmes raisons la
plupart des grandes villes se dote donc
de léproserie à l'extérieur de leurs
murs d'autres sont intégrés au monastère
dans des locaux séparés
quoi qu'il en soit les léproseries sont
généralement supervisés par des moellons
surtout de l'ordre de saint lazare
on y trouve aussi des personnes valides
qui se donne
la léproserie et se consacre aux soins
des malades par charité leur entrée en
léproserie et payantes en nature ou en
mode et afin d'assurer l'entretien des
lieux ils font des leurs voeux de
chasteté et de servir les pauvres
presque comme des moines et renonce à
l'ordre pour les malades
l'entrée en léproserie se faisait après
un examen médical une décision
judiciaire et une cérémonie religieuse
comme on l'a vu les la dhr les plus
riches devaient payer un droit d'entrée
pourrait séjourner en monnaies en
mobilier ou les deux à marseille tout
l'épreuve doit apporter son lit cédera
le ménage qui lui sera nécessaire et un
peu d'argent
halim les nouveaux malades doivent payer
15 livres tournoi s'ils sont de la ville
et 25 cl sont de l'extérieur et doivent
encore à mener leurs propres affaires
les pauvres sont reçus sans payer la
plupart du temps ont trouvé cinq à huit
malades dans chaque léproserie
exceptionnellement une vingtaine ou plus
leur espérance de vie il était de 3 5
ans avec là encore des exceptions à
haguenau un malade parce 22 ans dans sa
léproserie la vie en communauté implique
des règles
les malades sont régis par celle de
saint-augustin comme dans les hôpitaux
on y trouve des rituels spécifiques
comme les fêtes d'entrée pour les
nouveaux venus ou les processions dans
les dortoirs pour asperger les malades
de bénite les lépreux sont autorisés à
participer à des foires à voyager entre
léproserie et à effectuer des
pèlerinages ils peuvent aussi voir leur
famille et celle ci peut leur rendre
visite
le reste de leur temps est consacré à la
liturgie les les preuves sont plutôt
bien joué mais les progrès de beaulieu
propose par exemple du porc du boeuf du
mouton du potage devoir du poisson du
poulet du fromage et des oeufs en temps
de fêtes plutôt pas mal pour les boucles
bien voilà tu as trouvé ta vocation
le fait qu'il soit placé en léproserie
ne signifie pas qu'on renonce à les
soigner contrairement à certaines
croyances anciennes
ce ne sont en aucun cas des mouroirs les
médecins cherchent à ralentir le mal par
des bains des onguents des fumigations
des cataplasmes des ventouses
ils ont bien conscience qu'on ne guérit
pas de la lettre mais cherche surtout à
soulager le mal de leurs patients il
existe une grande différence entre les
lépreux admis dans des institutions
importantes qui bénéficient de dons et
ceux qui se retrouvent dans des hameaux
à l'épreuve sans moyens de subsistance
tu as les progrès de la rode par exemple
est un acteur économique important de la
région grâce à son patrimoine foncier
est assez investi
les autres malades ceux qui ne trouvent
pas de bonnes places sont autorisés à
cultiver leurs terres et à vendre leurs
produits
donc on fabrique des cordages de bateau
un métier qui leur est réservé et pour
les autres il reste la quête les la dhr
sont autorisés à sortir de leurs
léproserie pour l'aumône avec des règles
variable selon les villes
à certaines périodes de l'année
seulement pendant les fêtes religieuses
selon les jours à des endroits précis
ils n'ont pas le droit de manger et de
boire en ville ni de découcher tant
qu'ils peuvent aller s'acheter des
paquets de pâtes je ne vois pas problème
contrairement aux croyances la clique
est du lépreux ne lui sert pas à faire
fuir les personnes saines qui
l'entourent mais à faire l'aumône c'est
un instrument constitué de tablettes en
bois sur laquelle deux petites planches
viennent frapper puisque la maladie
touche les cordes vocales
elle permet d'appeler les passants sans
s'user inutilement et de leur signaler
qu'il ya les pros pas loin qui mendient
d'autres les preuves ne sont pas
intégrés à des léproseries ce qui rend
le nombre de malades d'autant plus
difficile à établir
il s'agit de lépreux nomades échappé ou
exclus de leur léproserie ou qui
n'avaient pas les moyens ou ont refusé
d'y entrer ce sont ceux qui inquiètent
le plus les populations parce qu'ils
sont incontrôlables nous transmettre la
maladie et ont parfois recours au vol
pour vivre à mesure que les la dhr sont
invités à entrer en léproserie des
interdits à leur encontre voit le jour
selon les villes ils ne peuvent plus
entrer à l'église dans les lieux publics
ou les marchés s'approchait des
fontaines des enfants manger avec des
personnes saines ou même touché de la
nourriture en dehors de celles qu'ils
ont achetés se déplacer sur leurs habits
spécifique parler à quelqu'un sans se
mettre sous le vent circuler dans les
rues étroites
la ville de lille est interdit d'accès
aux lépreux à partir de 1239 à périgueux
ils peuvent traverser la ville sans y
séjourner un salon les lettres peuvent
se déplacer librement même au marché
puisqu'ils ont juste l'interdiction de
toucher les produits qui sont en vente
malgré ces interdictions les lépreux
sont donc plus ou moins intégrés à la
société
contrairement à ce que les historiens
pensé auparavant ils vivent reclus et
non en exclu errare humanum est
l' attitude à leur égard se durcit
surtout à partir du 13ème siècle on voit
que de nombreux règlements du
son prix à cette période ce durcissement
correspond à une évolution des
mentalités à la fin du moyen-âge
la société change d'attitude vis-à-vis
des minorités on pense qu'elles vont à
l'encontre de l'unité tant recherchée
pour les gens de la fin du moyen-âge la
diversité c'est le mal quelle tolérance
parce que vous perdiez de son mieux
peut-être on retrouve ce changement de
mentalité dans la religion mais aussi
dans le domaine du droit
de ce fait ce sont les la dhr errants
qui sont le plus stigmatisés au même
titre que toutes les populations
marginales les mendiants les animaux
errants les prostituées mais léproserie
établi depuis longtemps et bien intégré
à leur territoire reste mieux tolérés
c'est aussi à partir de cette période
que le rituel d'entrée en léproserie
prend la forme d'une sorte d'enterrement
comme on l'a vu au paravent l'idée était
plutôt d'organiser une cérémonie
d'entrer en religion
l'autre raison de ce durcissement est la
préoccupation de plus en plus grande
pour la santé publique surtout à partir
du 14 ème siècle où la paix est apparue
en occident la question de la contagion
devient plus importantes et ont fui les
contacts des procès sont aussi
organisées contre les faux l'épreuve qui
vivrait de la charité ou essaierait
d'entrer en léproserie pourrait couler
des jours tranquilles en 1321 une vague
de persécutions à l'encontre des lépreux
cours dans le sud de la france et ont
conduit un grand nombre au bûcher
l'ordonnancé royale 2371 oblige les la
dhr de paris à rejoindre une léproserie
sans délai à avignon au 15e siècle la
ville verse un droit à la léproserie
pour que ses occupants dans sortent pas
et les malades étrangers sont refoulés
par des chasseurs de l'épreuve payés par
la municipalité
entre les progrès de l'hygiène la fin
des croisades et la persécution de plus
en plus grands dont ils sont victimes et
qui les exclut encore plus de la société
quand ils ne sont pas carrément tuer le
nombre de l'épreuve diminué au 14ème
siècle d'abord dans le nord de la france
puis en descendant vers le sud
l'ordre des chevaliers de saint lazare
et dissaux à la fin du xvème siècle au
milieu du xvième siècle la maladie est
considérée comme vaincus en europe les
léproseries sont presque vides
elles sont données en 1672 à l'ordre
restaurer de saint lazare et du mont
carmel
un ordre religieux qui n'a plus de
rapport avec le soin d'électrons la
lèpre ne disparaît pas totalement en
oeuvre
on trouve encore quelques cas en espagne
en france en norvège au 19e siècle le
sanatorium de fontis dans la province de
valence accueille de nombreux malades
entre 1909 et 1980 et dernière
léproserie de voir ferme à cette période
les quelques cas détectés chaque année
est temps pris en charge
individuellement le premier traitement
contre la lèpre est mis en place en 1944
et a été améliorée depuis ne faut pas
oublier l'outre-mer puisqu'on trouve
encore des cas de lèpre à mayotte ramené
par les comores et en guyane à cause de
la frontière brésilienne
si les léproseries européennes sont
transformés en musées et lieux de
mémoire dans le reste du monde la
maladie n'a pas dix pages
déjà parce que les continents se sont
refusés le passé allègrement l'europe et
l'inde ont contaminé la chine via la
route de la soie la colonisation
européenne a contaminé l'afrique de
l'ouest et l'amérique
la première des produits d'amérique est
fondée par cortes lui-même pour les
conquistadors malades uniquement sur ce
continent la lèpre a été transmise au
tattoo seul autre animal que l'homme à
en être atteints et qui transmet à son
tour la maladie aux humains les pays
touchés prennent des mesures diverses
contre cette maladie souvent sévères et
raciale le japon pratique la castration
forcé jusqu'en 1996 en australie après
la contamination d'un citoyen par un
aborigène en 1892 il est interdit aux 10
aborigènes de franchir le 30e parallèle
qui prend alors le nom de l'epr line de
nos jours les principaux foyers de la
lèpre sont l'inde le brésil le népal
d'indonésie on comptait 230 mille
nouveaux malades dans le monde en 2012
des chiffres toutefois en forte
diminution depuis le début du 21e siècle
et un total variant selon les études
entre 3 et 10 millions de lépreux
s'il existe maintenant un traitement il
n'y a toujours pas de vaccin contre
cette maladie
ces malades continuent de véhiculer une
image négative qui oblige le conseil des
droits de l'homme a rappelé en 2008
toutes personnes atteintes de la lèpre
ainsi que les membres de leurs familles
doivent être traités avec dignité comme
des individus et sont en droit de
bénéficier des droits et des libertés
fondamentaux de la personne humaine
voilà j'espère que cet épisode vous a
plu et intéressé j'ai pas eu le temps de
sortir de vidéo en octobre pour vous
l'avez sûrement remarqué c'est pour ça
que vous est diffusé du coup le bêtisier
de time warp faisait un petit moment
qu'il était dans les bacs étaient qu'il
était accessible aux contributeurs comme
ça tout le monde a pu en bénéficier
je rappelle aussi plusieurs choses dont
j'ai un tipi et ayew type si vous voulez
financer les vidéos de liens sont dans
la description et j'ai également sorti
un livre début septembre qui se trouve
ici
mais si vous le souhaitez qui peut aussi
se trouver dans le veau librairie si
vous le commandez magret confinement
vous pouvez toujours vous rapprocher des
librairies qui pratiquent le click and
collect bien aller sur la livre et les
points comme par exemple qui est ainsi
plutôt sympa il me semble donc cette
année par lequel je parle de la vie
quotidienne au moyen âge à travers
différents sujets j'en ai déjà parlé
dans d'autres vidéos de jeux pas trop
revenir dessus
on se retrouve le mois prochain c'est à
dire en décembre pour un jean todt à la
dass et aussi je pense pour une vidéo
sur les films que j'ai vus cette année
ils sortirent 2020 même si évidemment il
y en a un petit peu moins que les années
précédentes mais j'ai quand même trouvé
quelques films plutôt sympathique voilà
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo et à bientôt donc
jadis m'avait
née douce douce à l'oeil étonné ton
coeur jadis m'avait donné crois tu que
je les oublie
mais je les prie si bien ma douce qu'on
ne peut plus me l'arraché mon coeur est
pareil à la mousse à quoi l'on n'ose
plus touchés crois-tu qu'un si je
m'abandonne un coeur se donne un coeur
se prend un coeur se rend comme il se
donne un choeur ce2
et se prend les prêts les pros garde ta
lettre
garde ta lettre avait thakur l'épreuve
l'épreuve chanteuse tav être car je ne
veux plus ton amour je mourrai donc près
de ses bords la môme sera - afone avec
la lettre sur mon corps qu'avec la
laideur dans mon âme